look who it is
first thing i want to tell you
is
tonight was phenomenal magical magical
as much as i was worried about taking
some sassy girls and doing a ballad
it was pretty amazing
dallas
kenley and tiny t please step forward
kinley i think you're a phenomenal
dancer
but we have to work on your singing
tiny to you didn't have a part tonight
i wish you did
and i think your mom wished you did too
you weren't prepared this week
well what you did you did good when it
was your time to sing you sang
you remind me a lot of jojo and your
glass is always half full
it's cool it's a cool trait to have
dallas
i think tonight you were an angel on
stage
as hard as it is to bring the house down
with a ballad you did
and you did it your way
and i hope tonight
when you go to bed
you sleep in your exo and z jacket
[Music]
it's my dream come true
did i not make it
did i not make it
guys let me finish i'm not finished okay
it's okay it's okay i'm sorry
it's hard
it's
hard i promise you i understand what
you're going through i've been there
with jojo it's hard it's hard this is
the most important thing in the world to
me
i want to make this as fast as i can
hey guys we've got a new weekly show
every thursday on the e news channel
featuring celebrities revealing their
favorite and funniest dms be sure to
check out this week's episode of down in
the dms featuring bretman rock so click
here and check out the whole playlist
now